you're uh both worldclass
Debaters um even public in intellectuals
if I can say that Jesus real hard here I
know uh you both care about the truth
what is your process of arriving at the
truth uh I think it's really important
to everybody will say that they're
objective and that they are nonpartisan
I think it's really important to have
mental safeguards for bad opinions um so
for instance like a couple things that
I'll ask myself is for a particular
debate that I'm having like can I argue
convincingly both sides of the debate if
I can't I won't bother having the debate
because I realize that I'm probably too
partisan dug in if I can't even
represent like an opposite argument here
um another question that you might ask
yourself is like well what would it take
to convince you out of a certain
position um if you know if you feel very
strongly that uh you know Medicare for
all is a good you know system by which
to run the United States Healthcare and
somebody says well what would it take
you to convince you otherwise if you
can't even fathom like would it take to
convince me otherwise you're probably
too dug into a position so I think if
you go through life saying like well I
try my best to be unbiased rather than
saying I try to best my best be aware of
my biases because the latter is more
realistic and the former is literally
impossible unless you're a computer uh
yeah so I think having like actual
mental practices that you engage in to
try to counter some of the biases that
you have is more important than trying
to pretend that you're free of all
biases and then consuming all your media
from One Source yeah Ben uh so I mean I
agree with a lot of that I I I think
that the easiest practical guide is read
a bunch of different things from a bunch
of different sources and where they
cross is probably the set of fact and
then everything else is extrapolated
opinion from different premises that
that's the that that's sort of the short
story so read read the New York Times
and Breitbart and they're going to
disagree on a lot but if the core of the
story and the daily wire certainly read
the daily wire if you read the daily
wire and you read The Washington Post
and there's a and there's a Nexus of the
same thing then you can pretty well
guarantee that at least you know if if
it's if we're all Blind Men feeling the
Elephant at least if we're all feeling
the trunk we know that there's a trunk
there right you may not know what the
elephant is and if you're feeling frisky
then watch Destiny as well um thanks
you've talked about you know having a
conversation debating Ben for a long
time what is your favorite thing about
Ben Shapiro my favorite thing about Ben
Shapiro is at least when we're in
election season he's very critical of
his own party I appreciate that um that
doesn't I feel like Ben generally tries
adhere more to the fact-based arguments
than other conservatives that I listen
to which is something that I appreciate
because it's more fun to fight on kind
of like the factual grounds of
discussing things like foreign policy or
whatever rather than people that only
inhabit the idealistic or philosophical
grounds because they don't want to learn
about any of the facts so I appreciate
that Ben you've gotten a chance to talk
to Destiny now what what do you like
about the guy a lot of the same sorts of
things but it's really fun to see how
you do your process that is a cool thing
that is a cool thing it's a gift to the
audience because honestly doing what we
do so much of what we we do is sitting
and reading and being behind closed
doors and educating yourself and talking
with people but getting to watch you do
it in real time is is a really cool
window into how people think and how
people learn that's a really neat thing
well gentlemen this was incredible it's
an honor thank you for doing this today
he thanks a lot yeah thanks for having
me